ciao ragazzi allora so che ho una luce
tipo da apparizione della madonna
però ecco non riuscivo a far vedere in
un altrimenti sembrava una specie di
disegnatore forse sono un po bruciato
ma chi se ne frega a me tolgo le rughe
barbara d'urso dolce il motivo per cui
faccio questo video è perché io ho un
problema è solo un po stanco e tenerlo
nascosto i social mi fanno sentire una
merda cioè io mi addormento piangendo la
notte vivo instagram ogni volta nella
pro rischio la possessione demoniaca
ma me lo spirito è se vedete il noe
instagram ci sono solo selphy scattati a
cazzo sembra tipo la raccolta delle
fototessere della patente l'unica cosa
che ho capito di instagram è che serve a
farti sentire povero a questo ci sono
arrivato su instagram hanno tutti queste
sfide pazzesche dove tipo si fanno foto
di un hotel di lusso oppure stanno
all'exfila 3 sta minkia o a faber
aperitivi sulle terrazze più alte del
mondo io quando vedo queste foto da
ricchi cm manca subito non lo so la
semplicità di gemma del sud oppure le
atmosfere sognanti e oniriche di tacchi
alti laura scimone sarà kennedy io me lo
chiedo di pochi fine ha fatto quel web
in cui la speranza per un futuro
migliore proprio non esisteva affatto
io lo ammetto io io oggi sento questa
questo press
ma te stai zitta stampante l'ansia di di
questi ricchieri dichiari che se tu non
sorseggi champagne i compagni a
dell'atto migliore amica rihanna non sei
nessuno lo sento questo pressing io tipo
nel mio instagram non lo so fotografo
penso un pezzente fotografo loew che mi
per la pastasciutta di nonna la domenica
ma non ce l'avete le donne come
veramente a voi pensate come me ne fotte
qualcosa di far vedere che cosa mangio
no non siete i miei dietologi
anche perché se lo fosse lì dove far
causa poi però all'improvviso tutti ma
che c'è un imac e mi faccio io me li
mangio se tetti di lasagna europee non
mi faccio una foto agli addominali due
secondi dopo anche perché non ci sono
invece no questi tifosi sparano dei
panini con tipo dentro dei bambini
fritti c'è mamma
all'orrore e maionese ai due secondi
dopo riga stanno in spiaggia malnutriti
maca colombotto questi e non voglio
neanche parlare delle vacanze le vacanze
c'è io a volte vedo foto di posti che
secondo me son fatte al computer posti
dove l'acqua è così trasparente che io
riesca vede sottomarini in lontananza e
così ogni giorno della loro vita barca
sull'amaca appesi a una palma col cocco
in mano a quando minchia lavorano poi
ragazzi ci stanno queste persone che si
vestono con abiti di altissima moda ma
che hanno un gusto proprio cioè così
basso cioè che se ti porti di gli occhi
riesce a sentire in sottofondo coco
chanel che si richerà nella tomba o
quelle di magari che stanno di spalle
che reggono la meno del ragazzo mentre
stanno davanti a un tempio tibetano che
a me verrebbe da dirgli ma ti togli dal
calcio che la tua nuca mi copre i big
bad all piedi sporchi di sabbia sul
bagnasciuga o quelli che si fanno le
foto al cesso o quelli che fotografano
frullati dietetici che sembrano vomito o
tremonti dica che io l'ho capito che il
sole tramonta la quarantesima foto che
mi posti dell'orizzonte la ho capito
fanno tutti le stesse foto hanno tutti
la stessa vita ma soprattutto non ne
potete svegliate mattina avere già in
rim belle
io instagram non abbiamo un ottimo
rapporto no se qualcuno anzi lei e
consigli per aiutarmi a superare questo
scoglio ecco sarei lieto di sentirli e
se volete che parli con affetto di un
altro social scrivetelo nei commenti